you see her now you don't Megan the
stallion repost this photo that crops
Cara Delevingne out of her and Doja cat
shot at the Billboard Music Awards and
it's causing chatter about Cara's quirky
interactions with Meg throughout the
night
it all started on the red carpet when
fans noticed Cara seemed to be at the
Billboard Awards with the rapper while
Meg was posing away fans spotted Cara
peeking around the corner hyping her up
and at one point Cara lifted a part of
Megan's dress then she proceeded to toss
it in the air seemingly trying to help
Meg get the perfect shot thank you now
check out this moment when they were
seated inside the award show and Megan
won best female rap artist some fans
couldn't help but notice Cara's reaction
and the Billboard Music Award goes to
[Applause]
[Music]
one person tweeted quote why every time
I see Cara Delevingne her tongue out and
she and Megan's face While others
tweeted memes like this one about Meg
trying to get away from Cara the entire
night
[Applause]
but this Twitter user might have
actually nailed what's going on quote
I've read some negative press about her
behaving oddly but I think she's just
excited for her friend and it truly
might be a friendship here check out
this clip billboard shared of Megan Cara
and dojicad at the show with Doja cat
having a front row seat to Megan and
Cara sitting side by side
in Meg's reaction
yeah she calls Cara her model
so the rapper re-sharing that crop photo
just might be harmless after all
[Music]